With the view transform in place, we now have all our coordinates in the
cameras frame of reference. What we now want to do is define a box in this
space to contain everything we're going to render. It's sort of like defining
the size of a stage. As noted before, the orthographic camera's definition is
to give a left, right, top, bottom, near, far set of values to define this box.
These six numbers define the corners of a rectangular box in the view space of
your camera. The first time I explained it, we made a box and then oriented it
in space. What's happening as far as the matrices go is the reverse. We first
orient the world to the camera's view of things. Then define our box with
respect to the camera. In practical terms we usually make the left and right
the opposites, along with the top and bottom. The near value is often zero,
though can be any number. The idea is that the view matrix moved everything in
the world to be placed relative to the lens of our camera. Creating the
orthographic camera itself, makes a projection matrix. The box defined by the
projection matrix is then in front of the camera and symmetric around its view
axis. This box called the view volume in fact performs a projection. We're not
just defining a box, we're saying take everything in this box and project it
onto the plus z side of the box and make an image. You may have been wondering
why are we looking down the negative z angle axis. This is done because it
makes for a right handed coordinate system for the camera. The y direction is
up. X is to the right. Giving a Cartesian coordinate system for the image
formed. To keep things right handed, the z axis must be pointing toward the
viewer. Meaning we have to look down the negative z axis. That said, three j s
thinks about the orthographic camera is going in a positive direction. So the
far value is specified as a distance along the negative z axis. Our chain of
matrixes adds this projection to the front. In other words, the projection is
applied next. When applied, a coordinate will get a new value in this
projection's frame of reference. This frame uses what are called Normalized
Device Coordinates or NDC for short. These NDC coordinates are in the range
from -1 to 1 for X, Y, and Z. We'll talk more about this transform in a minute,
but the point is, is that whatever is inside the box will have coordinates
transformed to this new range.